Lundi
non oh on l'
appelle St lundi mais mardi c'est comme
B l'appelle stor et lundi mardi c'est
mauvais tu sais mercredi c'est pire il y a
tout si
triste l'attente s'envole vendredi samedi je
joue à
heyle FES vendredi samedi toi et moi
jouons dimanche je  va à l'église agenouille-toi à
genoux je
prie je prie
Seigneur Seigneur aie Mery oh mon salut
heureux
Seigneur Seigneur aie pitié de
moi j'ai perdu mon bébé, ne veux-tu pas s'il te plaît renvoie-le
chez moi
écoute bébé ce n'est pas une joie mais ça
m'a appris  comment
rouler ouais et mon bébé n'est pas ivre
mais ça m'a appris à
rouler il est dans une fête frappe-le au
milieu chérie et
bouge-le sur le
côté Hé écoute un et un font deux deux
et deux font quatre fille tu es venue
ici  en frappant à ma porte, ils appellent ça
orageux J et
B tu sais que mercredi est pire
ils ont
dit je dis Seigneur, aie pitié
Seigneur, aie
pitié Seigneur, aie
pitié, j'ai perdu mon bébé, ne veux-tu pas me les renvoyer
chez moi